because God means the creator of
everything yeah because everything yeah
and everything submit to him
to God if God submits someone else he
cannot be the same God who everything's
complete to him Jesus in the Bible said
I'm going to my God and your God so
Jesus is a God and you know what it's
very interesting Jesus said that he
doesn't know the hour in the Quran same
thing Prophet Muhammad said about that
day of judgment Allah told us in the
Quran Muhammad they asked about the hour
he said no one knows it no one knows it
except Allah
except Allah and this exactly what it
goes in line with the statement of Jesus
let me tell you about something about
this guy yeah we're all together
something about the Trinity yes yeah
yeah we we have Jesus yeah yeah like we
we have God yeah God is the father yeah
we call him as father
yeah I know the father is God and God is
the father then we get Jesus Christ is
he good
Jesus Christ is God and God
and then we have the Holy Spirit that
filled us within and the Holy Spirit is
God and God is the holy spirit so how
many God you have one God
we have one girl
is the father fully God by himself
is the father fully called by himself
yeah of course so we have one God
I have some teaching for you I know the
Bible very well
that you can no we believe in Jesus we
respect him we love him
yeah
I think that's where the problem is okay
so how can we understand God who should
use our brain or or the cow's brain if
you have a brain and a soul and a heart
this is the Bible by the way the Bible
trust me
Islam is the best for you Jesus
Muslim
have a nice weekend take care of
yourself